i was uh
on a social network last night uh in a
clubhouse
yeah i don't know if you've heard of it
i was wait i have to ask you about this
because i was invite i'm invited to do a
clubhouse i don't know what that means
a tech reporter has invited me to do a
clubhouse about my new book
uh that's awesome uh well let me know
when because i'll show up
but what is it okay so first of all let
me just mention that i was in a
clubhouse
uh room last night and i kept plugging
your exactly what exactly
you said about uh passion so we'll talk
about it it was a room that was focused
on burnout
okay uh but first clubhouse
is a kind of fascinating place in terms
of
your mind would be very interesting to
analyze this place
because you know we talk about email we
talk about social networks
but clubhouse is something very
different and i've encountered
in other places discord and so on that's
voice only communication so it's a bunch
of people in a room they're just
now eyes closed all you hear is their
voices
real time real time live it only happens
live you're technically not allowed to
record
but some people still do and you know
especially when it's big
big conversations but the whole point is
that they're live
and there's different structures like on
discord it was so fascinating i
have this discord server that would have
hundreds of people in a room together
right we're all just little icons that
commute and i mute our mics
okay and so you're sitting there not so
it's just
voices and you're able with hundreds of
people
to not interrupt each other but first of
all
like as a dynamic system yeah like you
see icons just like mics muted or not
muted basically yeah well so everyone's
muted
and they unmute and they start it starts
flashing yeah
and oh so you're like okay let me uh get
precedence
yeah so it's the digital equivalent of
when you're in a conversation at like a
faculty meeting
and you sort of uh like kind of make
some noises like while the other
person's finishing and
so people realize like okay this person
wants to talk next but now it's purely
digital you see a flashing
but in a faculty meeting which is very
interesting like even as we're talking
now
there's a visual element that seems to
increase the probability of interruption
yeah when it's just darkness you
actually
listen better and you don't interrupt so
like if you create a culture there's
there's always going to be but
they're they're actually exceptions
everybody adjusts they kind of evolve to
the
the beat of the room okay that's one
fascinating aspect like okay
that's weird because it's different than
like a zoom call where there's video
yeah uh it's just audio you think video
ads
but actually seems like it subtracts the
second aspect of it that's fascinating
is when it's no video just audio there's
an intimacy
it's feel it's weird because with
strangers
it you you connect you know in a much
more real way it's very
it's similar to podcasts yeah but
with a lot of people with a lot of
people and new people huh and then you
and they they bring okay first of all
different voices like low voices and
like high voices and
and it's it's more difficult to judge in
discord you couldn't even see
uh the people it was a culture where you
do funny
profile pictures as opposed to your
actual face your clubhouse it's your
actual face
so you can tell like as an older person
younger person in discord you couldn't
you just have to judge based on the
voice
but there's a there's something about
the listening
and the intimacy of being surprised by
different
strangers that feels almost like um
a party with friends and friends of
friends you haven't met yet but you
really like
now clubhouse also has an interesting
innovation where there's a large crowd
that just listens and there's a stage
and you can bring people up onto stage
so only people on stage are talking
and you can have like five six seven
eight sometimes 20 30 people on stage
and then you can also have thousands of
people just listening i see
so there's a i don't know a lot of
people are being surprised by this
why is it called a social network it
seems like it doesn't have there's not
social links there's not a
feed that's trying to harvest attention
it feels like a communication
uh so the social uh network aspect is
you follow
people yeah and the people you follow
now this is like the first social
network that's actually
correct use of follow i think
you're more likely to see the rooms
they're in
so there's a your feed is a bunch of
rooms that are going on right now
okay and the people you follow
are the ones that will increase the
likelihood that you'll see the room
they're in
and so the final result is like there's
a list of really interesting rooms like
uh i have all these i've been speaking
russian quite a bit there's practicing
uh but also just like talking politics
and philosophy in russian
i've never done that before but it
allows me to connect with that community
and then uh there's a community of like
it's funny but like i'll go in a
community of all african-american people
talking about race and i'll be welcomed
yeah
i've never had like i've literally never
been
in a difficult conversation about race
like with people from all over the place
it's like fascinating and
musicians jazz musicians i don't know
you could say that a lot of other places
could have created that culture i
suppose
twitter and facebook will offer that
culture but there's something about
this network as it stands now because it
ain't no android users
it's probably just because it's iphone
people yeah uh is there it's
conspiratorial or something
well like less listen i'm an android
person so i i got an iphone just for
this network yes it's funny yeah
uh is for now it's all like
there's very few trolls yeah there's
very few people that are trying to
manipulate the system and so on
so i don't know it's it's interesting
now the downside the reason you're going
to hate it
is because it's so intimate because it
pulls you in
and pulls in very successful people like
you just
ever like really successful productive
very busy people
uh it it
it's a huge time sink it's very
difficult to pull yourself out
interesting you mean once you're in a
room well no the uh leaving the room
is actually easy the beautiful thing
about a stage with multiple people
there's a little button that says leave
quietly okay
so cultural uh no etiquette wise it's
okay to just leave
yeah so you're i in a room when it's
just you and i it's a little awkward to
believe if you're asking questions i'm
just
gone yeah but and actually if you're
being interviewed for the book
that's weird because you're now in the
event
and you're supposed to but usually the
person interviewing would be like okay
it's time for you to go it's more normal
but the the
normal way to use the room it's like
you're just opening the app
and there'll be like i don't know sam
harris
uh eric weinstein
um i think joe rogan showed up to the
bill gates
these people on stage just like randomly
just plugged in
and then you step up on stage listen
maybe you won't
contribute at all maybe you'll say
something funny yeah and then you'll
just leave
yeah and there's uh the the addicting
aspect to it the reason it's the time
sink is you don't want to leave
what i've noticed about exceptionally
busy people yeah
that they love this this the their i
think might have to do with a pandemic
because might be a little bit yeah
there's a loneliness
yeah but also it's really cool people
yeah like
when was when was the last time you
talked to sam harris or whoever
like you think of anybody uh tyler like
a any
any faculty this is like what
universities strive
to create but it's taken cause you know
here's a cultural evolution try to get a
lot of interesting smart people together
that run into each other
we have really strong faculty in a room
together
with no scheduling this is the power of
it it's like you just
show up there's no none of that baggage
of scheduling and so on
and there's no pressure to leave uh
sorry no pressure to stay
it's very easy for you to leave you
realize that there's a lot of
constraints on meetings and like faculty
this uh like even stopping by
you know before the pandemic a friend or
faculty or colleague and so on
you know there's a weirdness about
leaving yeah but
here there's not a weirdness about
leaving so they've discovered something
interesting
the but the final result when you
observe it
is uh it's very fulfilling i think it's
very beneficial
but it's very addicting so you have to
make sure
you moderate yeah that's interesting and
okay well so maybe i'll try it i mean
look there's no
the things that make me suspicious about
other platforms aren't here
so the feed is not full of user
generated content
that is going through some sort of
algorithmic grading process with all the
weird incentives and nudging that does
uh and you're you're not producing
content that's being harvested
to be monetized by another company i
mean it it seems like it's more
uh ephemeral right you're here you're
talking the feed is just actually just
showing you
here's interesting things happening
right you're not jocking in the feed for
look i'm being clever or something and
i'm going to get a light count that goes
up and that's going to influence and
right and there's more friction there's
more cognitive friction i guess involved
in
listening to smart people versus uh
scrolling through
yeah there's something there so there's
no why are people so i see a lot of
there's all these articles that seem i
haven't really read them but
why are why are reporters negative about
this competition the new york times
wrote this article called
unfettered conversations happening on
clubhouse is
uh so i'm right in picking up a tone
from even from the headlines that
there's some like negative
vibes from the press no so i can say
let's say well i'll tell you what the
article was saying
which is uh they're having cancelable
conversations like the biggest people in
the world
almost trolling the press right and the
press is definitely for channing the
press yeah
the press but by saying that you just
you guys are looking for
click bait from our genuine human
conversations
and so so the i think the
honestly the press is just like what do
we do with this we can't
yeah um first of all it's a lot of work
for them okay
uh it's what naval says which is like
this is skipping the journalists
like they interview you if you go on
clubhouse the interview you might do
for the book would be with somebody
who's like a journalist and interviewing
you
yeah that that's more a traditional yeah
it'd be a good introduction for you to
try it
but the like the way to use clubhouse
is you just show up and it's like
again like me i'm sorry i'm like
i can't i keep mentioning sam harris as
if it's like the only person i know but
like a lot of these uh major faculty i
don't know max tegmark
like just just yeah major faculty just
sitting there and then you show up
and then uh i'll ask like oh don't you
have a book coming out or something
and then you'll talk about the book and
then you'll leave five minutes later
because you have to go get coffee and
interesting so like that's the yeah it's
not the journalistic
you're not gonna actually enjoy the
interview as much because it'll be like
the normal thing yeah like you're there
40 minutes or an hour and there'll be
questions from the audience
right like i'm doing an event next week
for the book launch where it's like
jason fried and i are
talking about email yeah but it's using
some more
like a thousand people who are there to
watch virtually but it's using some sort
of traditional
webinar clubhouse would be a situation
where that could just happen informally
like
i jump in like jason's there and then
someone else jumps in and and
yeah that's interesting but for now it's
still closed
so even though there's a lot of
excitement and there'll be
quite famous people just sitting there
listening to you yeah
but the numbers aren't exactly high so
you're talking about
rooms like even the huge rooms are like
just
a few thousand right and this is this is
probably soho in the 50s or something
too
just because of the exponential growth
give it seven more
months and if you let one invite be gets
two invites because four invites begins
pretty soon it'll be
everyone and then the rooms in your feed
are gonna be whatever
uh marketing performance enhancing drugs
or something like that
yeah but then and a bunch of competitors
there's already like 30 plus competitors
sprung up twitter spaces so twitter is
creating a competitor
that's going to likely destroy clubhouse
yeah because they just have a much
larger user base
and they already have a social network
so yeah i
i would be very cautious of course yeah
with the addictive element but it
doesn't just like you said
this particular implementation in its
early stages doesn't have the like
yeah the the uh well it doesn't have the
context switching problem
yeah you'll just switch fantastically
and you'll be stuck
yeah the keep a context is great yeah
yeah
and but then i think the best way i've
found to use it
is uh to acknowledge that these things
pull you
in yeah so i've used it in the past
uh like almost you know i'll go get a
coffee and i'll tune into a conversation
as if that's how i use podcasts
sometimes i'll just like play a little
bit of a podcast
and then you know i can just turn it off
the problem with these
is it pulls you in it's really
interesting and then the other problem
that you will experience
is like somebody will recognize you yeah
and then they'll be like oh lex come on
up
come on no way i had a question for you
and then it takes a lot for you to go
like to to ignore that yeah yeah so
yeah and then you pulled in and it's
fascinating and it's really cool people
so it's like a source of a lot of joy
but
it is yet to be very very very careful
you